where the anger
[Music]
my name is Jen underdahl and I was the
visual effects producer on Marvel's
endgame my main tasks are to work with
our directors John Anthony and our
studio heads to make sure that the
vendors we are bringing on board are the
right vendors for the the scope of work
that we have for the show I have to look
at these two movies as a single project
it Stannis's movie infinity ward's so in
2016 we knew that very early on we were
going to need to test this before we
even shot a frame of footage to give
some sort of ease and peace of mind to
our filmmakers that yes this guy could
carry 2/3 of them we worked with Josh's
people in our production staff to bring
him in and work with Joe and Anthony we
did some very early testing and a mocap
volume we had head cam setup he's got
dots on his face and those two cameras
are capturing his facial performance so
we kind of did this this whole gauntlet
yeah so gauntlet of testing and scanning
capturing every aspect of Josh's face
and in different range of motions so not
only was it a technical discovery for us
it was also a character discovery for
Josh Joe and Anthony when we found we
kind of had to imagine Panos being this
big mean you know kind of over-the-top
character but how Josh played it was
beautiful his performance was was
menacing but subtle terrifying
him but in little flinches so we
realized at that moment that we really
needed to have a company that could
capture all that and pull his
performance through the prosthetics so
that when you are like this on things
you felt the terror in your bones with
his character history you had
[Music]
traditional domain to Wed over key in
thousands of development so we gave them
all this scanning data we gave them all
this footage and in the end a couple
months later they turned around a
version of panels that look crazy like
Josh
ideally in any situation when you have a
digital character you want to have two
actors acting to one another that's
where the magic happens and we can
replace it digitally but we certainly
can't manufacture that performance so
it's really important for us to put the
actors in a situation where they are
speaking to one another face-to-face
eye-to-eye line to eye line now it gets
complicated by the fact that phallus is
15 feet tall
if josh is in movement for example
fighting with anybody we put proxies on
him we put like displacement suits
that's so that if you have to touch him
or interact with him in any way the
opposing actors hands are in the correct
position eyelines same thing we will
oftentimes put a eyeline on a pole on a
backpack he looks kind of silly on set
but he's pretty awesome about it but
oftentimes whatever we try as much as
possible to get eyeline to eyeline
maybe smashed a few things along the way
I think it's good to hurt us but
whatever
so the whole goal was smart Hawk was to
bring old Hulk together with dr. banner
what was that gonna look like I put the
brains and the Brawn together and now
they give me best of both worlds
borrowing from the 2d designs that came
from Marvel we then had to sculpt smart
Hulk into a 3d model you always want to
have little anchor points in your
digital characters where you see your
actors features to some degree I mean
everybody kind of fell in love with him
actually when we started to see him come
to life and the more we found we
incorporated mark the more his
performance also stayed true to the
digital performance when I had to
gauntlet the stones I really tried to
bring her back ILM they had done Hulk
from Avengers 1 so we knew that they
already knew this character they knew
his skin how to deal with this skin
technically they knew his musculature
inside and out so really blending him
with a more humanoid proportioned
character was the right way to go
casting wise for for that character so
we find that in visual effects the more
we stay out of the way of the filmmakers
and the actors the the better results
we're gonna get the footage is what we
derive all of our artistry from so when
that is genuine when that is fluid when
that is moving we really get the best of
both worlds in a case like Smart Hulk
you want to make sure that mark is
interacting on set with all the other
characters in the case of the Avengers
compound he needs to be there with Tony
he needs to be there with Natasha used
to be in that scene so we'll set up a
motion capture volume on set so he's
surrounded by cameras and he's animo cap
suit so again visual effects needs to
really in all of our technical gathering
we need to take a backseat to to what's
happening all the Performing Arts have
their own own sense okay
I said so in the case of Captain America
what would a Super Soldier look like if
he had aged 106 years what would his
skin look like so we did some
development with that getting targets
with our studio and our directors to say
hey you know is this where we should be
aiming once they bought off and what
that look was gonna be we then started
casting for skin double looking around
for an old guy who approximates the same
age and face shape of capital what cap
would be who shot in the same lighting
conditions right after Chris performs he
gives the same lines he who tries to
emulate Chris's performance as much as
possible so that it doesn't take a whole
lot of hammering when we go
dink onto Chris's face in addition to
the skin double you also need to give
him sort of an older man's body older
ends sort of overall profile so as
you've seen with skinny Steve in Captain
America one vola is able to take
significant size off of Chris Evans
pretty much in every instance on Captain
America one where we're shooting Chris
Evans it's Chris Evans
that's his body and he's a big dude we
need to get him down to a 90 pound
weakling to do so Lola will do an
overall warp on his body and literally
squish him down so that he fits in the
plate as this character they did the
same sort of thing though not with as
heavy a hand for old cap they took some
neck off of him so he wasn't quite as as
beefy here and who shrunk his shoulders
and sort of his overall profile to give
him that 106 year old the super-soldier
look now we've got em game fair and game
Thor has lost everything repeatedly so
he has dealt with it by eating a lot and
drinking a lot and playing video games
of course
so to get this character we fought
really hard to make sure that we had a
practical solution to this because we've
seen it done before you can put a body
suit on somebody and it can work
Marvel contacted and contracted legacy
effects to do the prosthetic and I'll be
darned I mean every little hair on that
thing every little bit of skin patch
it's super convincing so we were
thrilled and we saw that come through
because it impacts the performance again
you've got Chris Hemsworth really
getting into the part because of the
character he's embodying and for us it
was just cleanup work really there were
gonna be natural scenes as he's moving
his arms around there could be folds and
you had to kind of suture him into the
thing there so there was a seam down the
back that we had to clean up but by and
large that's legacies prosthetic and hem
sores hilarious performance our work is
super easy in those instances because
you know you're getting the best of both
worlds practical and visual effects you
want to go to space you want to go to
space puppy space in the case of rocket
for us
pretty easy cuz we just stolen guardians
we had to put him a new costume which
was super cool but I think all of the
the character work had been done pretty
early on him so it was just continuing
his arc as a character alright
you must be mom I got the thing come on
we gotta move there's no real reason to
put dots on Bradley Cooper space the
difference between a raccoon and a human
face is it's pretty far off we will when
we're in the room with him for a TR will
have different cameras on him so that we
can see whatever just stipulations he's
doing we can see his facial expressions
and we can take all that we can
translate it into that character I live
for the simple things like how much this
is gonna hurt you do have to make these
nonhumanoid things human you have to
sell it you have to love them you have
to you have to cheer for them you have
to feel their pain
and oftentimes you know that can come
down to just a simple layer of water in
the eye that we put in just to really
pull you emotionally into a scene so on
set we will have a body double Sean Gunn
who is remarkable at getting two rockets
four foot high and he just he folds
himself up it's it's crazy how he's able
to do it and walk and jump down from the
ledges and those are important as we
talked about because you want to have
your actors acting against one another
and also helps a great deal with camera
blocking so that our camera guy knows
how to go from a digital thing you know
to a live-action element this is the
fight of our lives and we're gonna win
whatever it takes you may have noticed
the time suits are a combination ant-man
Tony Stark and the Guardians Tech and
that took quite a while for us to land
on by the time we got a final version we
were already into principal photography
which we knew we're gonna build them
anyway because of how they needed to
nano on and off with Tony's Tech so it
ended up being that the costume
department they didn't have time to
develop fit and fabricate the all the
costumes for those hero characters so we
ended up doing it digitally and so you
you don't notice but every time you see
one of your heroes in that suit it's
digital challenge there was getting the
right color tone we also tried very
early on in previous the notion of
having the helmet be made of the
guardians of the galaxy breather mesh
that allowed them to travel into space
we have some early development of them
with that kind of being a bubble around
their head but as soon as we started
seeing it come up in the post of his
footage the directors were like don't
think that looks as heroic as it could
possibly look so we went ahead and
developed helmets for the suits the
guardians tech then just became the
visor
[Music]
for the final battle our department
provided us with an overall map of where
the different beats were gonna take
place and we staged our previews
accordingly there was a lot of
nondescript areas but then we had some
defining moments where we would try and
make it recognizable as an area with a
collapsed a for example or making sure
that the water was coming over was
distinguishable and sheer and gave me
that sort of that impact of water
rushing
don't worry she's got chills
for the woman of marvel scene where all
the female characters collect before
they take on Thanos
everybody was there on set for that day
so being on the stage with all of these
tremendous actors it was pretty pretty
cool moment to witness that was pretty
energetic and fundamental I think people
understood that they were watching
ultimately we ended up having to roto
some of our characters off during
specific action beasts and then
completely replace the entire background
that happened quite a bit it gives the
filmmakers more flexibility it allows
them to steal parts from one performance
to another part of the sequence so our
building these sets in full CG really
allows our filmmakers a lot of
flexibility not only with their
live-action elements but with the
digital replacements than when you have
a beat that doesn't cut together as
smoothly as you'd like
cat versus cap is an example of a lot of
green-screen being shot for what you
wouldn't otherwise think was an entirely
digital and synthetic environment we had
very bare-bones set when they were up on
the walkway for example we had that part
built we had the stairs built but pretty
much everything else was a digital build
all the glass all the building all the
background all the office furniture
everything is digital the background is
a is a plate of New York New York
skyline at appropriate height so that
you can get the building tops in the
distant background then you have another
layer of kind of closer buildings that
are more on two and a half D maybe not
solid 3d and then you've got your
building structures so the girders the
millions the all the glass all the
reflections off all the internal glass
the plants the telephones the desks
every little section of glass in that
environment
he's digital to shoot it we had Chris
Evans act both parts and then the
moments where they were interacting we
had a body double so you can get the
contact moment she could get the true
fight moments and then whenever the face
of the body devil was visible we can
convincingly do face replacements so why
not get your hero falling 30 feet in the
air why not get your hero getting you
know punched pretty hard were able to do
it so that sequence it was a combination
of Chris Evans shooting each side and
then when they interacted with the body
devil that is a full stop and want to
shout out to the stunt team because they
took some pretty hard Falls smacking
down those stairs so it was a really
impressive stunt
we're all pretty excited when Captain
Marvel came out and when we knew that we
were gonna get to work with his
character luckily we were standing on
the shoulders of the great effects team
that came before us so they had
developed this really beautiful binary
look that we were able to just get in
the hands of our vendors that
development was happening as we were
posting so it was a little bit of us
chasing them down the line but in the
end I mean I think I really loved where
they minded that like hirsute every time
you see it in the movie when she's in
her full costume is digital again the
designs for those suits were not ready
in time for us to photograph free so
when you saw her at the beginning as
she's rescuing Tony Stark when you see
her come back when she's talking to NAT
in the Avengers compound with rocket
nebula and then in the final battle when
she comes back and kind of saves the day
that's all the digital soup
in our world for visual effects we do
want to try and get as much practical as
we possibly can our supervisor made a
bet with a line producer that we would
have to replace the rat that appears
when Scott Lang is coming back from the
quantum realm to San Francisco and Dan
insisted that we could find a rat that
was trained that could actually behave
on set and our line producer was
convinced we're gonna have to replace it
for those of you who are curious that is
not a digital rat for all the things
that we do and for all the things that
we replace that is actually a practical
acting rat I don't have his name but
he's really there where'd he go
the blip effect that we ended up calling
it the sort of post snap people
disappearing look that was months of
development and it was supposed to be
quiet it was supposed to be elegant you
know a little bit of pain mixed in but
the pain was really supposed to be felt
by the audience and their characters
disappearing so we wanted to give that
silence to the viewership
capturing that we did about several
months of development we just kept
running sin after sin and landed on
something that the brothers really fell
in love with it was just running a lot
of samples over several months and
finally getting to getting to the look
the notion of having the characters
reform on-screen did come up but I think
everybody could visualize pretty clearly
that that would just be a little too
weird you don't really want to see that
and much more powerful if it happens off
screen the Tony snap that was
challenging in that we knew the
emotional weight that that was gonna
carry we as a as our part and it had to
take a very backseat to that moment to
that performance
so technically having the background in
there that was not a problem but finding
the right tone of the tendrils of the
Infinity stones eating the way at the
suit is a suit is struggling and
fighting to protect Tony and you know in
that moment that he's not powerful
enough to withstand what's coming and to
be able to portray that in a very quiet
visual way and be in the background of
what Robert was doing in that moment
well it was that's what it took some
time to get that right you'd be lucky to
find a dry eye on that one we're gonna
be okay
you can Reza I know it's gonna be really
hard for me in my career to top
achieving a Thanos and a smart Hulk I
mean those characters for visual effects
person I mean those are pretty pretty
peak so I'm enormous ly proud of the
work that that we did and of the vendors
who came to the table with our a-game
and continually challenging each other
to just get better and better so that
the fans in studio and everybody really
got performances from from these
characters that I think will live on in
history pretty significantly
[Music]
assemblé